WEO TWO ARIZONA LAWMAK
CT
L DUTY, AI
THEN SAYS INAR ARTICLE TWO
THE UNITED STATES
RE OUR
STIS MEANS YOU
VE TAGAINST FRAUD, THE
RESPONSIBILITY IYOS AND
CREDIBLE ADVOCACY CONG FROM T F
LLMET, GTHMAILPLEASE CON WILL
DON'T STAND UP, UP NOW, N
LEGAVED COUROR
NNY THP THE STEA 2SSESTO CHIEF E
ELECTI,  IG E THOMO RECUSE HIMSF
6th ASS ALL COMES IGHT.
CAN ANE WILL DO AT?
ASKED FOR Y F ENEEQUH
SE TS
RALLY, OITOLE T IGHT SHE WAS E A
T IN PIECEND
STAS SATELECTION CASES AND JANUA
AT THAT POT HET OFNVOLVEMENT, N
CALLS FOR HIM TO
SHOULD KNOW, THE FERUDR
MIGHTE QUESTIONED
T
THAT ISSUE IS SOLELYN THE
HANDS OF THETICE T.F JUSTICE JO,
NOT SIIN
JUDGMENT OF EACH
HAS R D IN THETS WHE A
CHALLENGEONE HAS, ONE AT SUPREM
LEVEL HAS WRONGLDET TO
RECUSE AOMAS TOOK
AND VERY PUBLIE ROBERTS.
E SAID>> COURT THAT WAS TOGETHE
11 YWAA FALO LOOKED FORWARD TOU
AND THAT WAS THEF  RIG
CONTRAST HE WANG.
WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU THAT HE
>> WELL, HE MIGHT HAVE
THOUTH
THINK ITS EXACTLY WHAT'SINHT NO
FIGHT OVER THE.
CLARENCES ISO CLOS G HI OLEV WA.
W FROM THE POLITICAL DTHAT T AE
JUSTICES ON THAT BUTHEN TH IF HE
HALIMBUTE MIGH IT AND WE'LL KNO
THE END OF